the Joe Rogan experience joy my day Joe
Rogan boy yeah man you pull it through
as you push it through it's like there's
no there's no banging on my wrist at all
okay
I don't feel anything if not my right
one is on my left it's just a timing
thing it's like as it's coming up like
you get it to hear and then all in one
motion for you should start like this
rear end quote I mean you're doing swing
swings is a different thing no no I know
but that's not I'm talking about those
should you so he started like this
uh-huh yeah yeah if you want to do
you're doing two hand clean left leg
yeah if you're going to hand cleans you
have one in each arm then you go like
this like that do you recommend a juicer
stuff I do the ones that this is great I
think I like that's my chance I like
doing two hands this it makes me work
full so that's the same with the call
it's called project tango and it's been
out for a little while but they made
some adjustments for the sake of IO and
it's a tablet it looks like a regular
tablet but what it actually has the
ability to do is to map 3d space in real
time so if you think of like VR
generally you put on a VR headset and
you're in whatever universe they want to
put you in this one is looking at the
actual thing so interacting with objects
is something you can still do even
though you're looking at a digital
representation of it I'm saying sounds
sounds weird but like a couch is still a
couch so you could you could like almost
stylize let's say you put like an
alligator on the couch next to you for
example like a completely active
scenario that you can interact with
physically and on top of that they have
the other use case scenario that I think
they're talking about is like in mapping
projects mapping internal spaces and
things like that but it's in a developer
mode right now so you can either hold it
up and do it like that normally and they
also build like a actual physical
headset for Toby wicked for green-screen
GPS where you could actually have GPS
and like oh so you're going in between
but the main one of the main
propositions is for robotics because
right now robots don't see very well and
this would essentially give robots the
ability
to see time and space similar is this
whole thing flying everywhere oh right
through that right into the back hope it
is happy I'm I'm worried it's is gonna
know shoot the whole thing off the whole
don't know you talking about 280 per
second so it's just it just kind of blow
right through that fucker
all right it's a small it's a tight
arrow that's very small aluminum and
carbon I probably like the iPhone
Partridge absolute perfection
Wow yeah I mean yo convicts equal the
old one with this so that's that's
pretty clean causal right I did a next
week oh my gosh awesome background angry
yeah yeah yeah that's on target I'm
almost edible yeah that's on target it's
just a matter of with these things
warming up a little bit
[Music]
that's gonna cut it sharp or is it like
a like a point there's a pony yeah
definitely a point yeah yeah while he's
setting up do we want to get this done
to do it should do chef yeah yeah yeah
why you arm up this week yeah yeah bring
it out here bring the FSO being here I
guess
all right here I don't even gonna need
the big bow book yeah he's it a little
easier to manage Aswath
know your man just W ten pounds more
pulling it is right in the throat and so
no it's 100% unnecessary oh and we're
actually going to shoot the thing I'll
explain what this is and what if those
bowl and yeah it's a lot like can you
review this one oh you did well like if
you wanted to do this right away if you
want to do this experiment this is no
this is one of the most powerful if not
you know the other one the other one
that I happen to tiny potluck is the
most powerful compound both avoid cells
you have to wear it's special from the
factory like you can't even buy this
from Lowe's store you can buy a regular
less if you count one from above summer
but if you want like this
order table that one is special for the
90-pound one the other one called an
idol it's called a point factor
290-pound draw away it shoots 490 green
arrows and 288 feet per second this is
one of the most powerful pose no man
it's like you could conceivably make
something that's more powerful like I've
heard 100 pound bubbles but very few
companies make them what is hated here
this is all about the distance this is
all this one doesn't have a sight tape
on if you look at this one you see the
sight
[Music]
boss left
yeah is that going away Oh smell the
burn it's bright for barbecue if you
smell it aro it's brie cheese plastic oh
shit yeah yeah yeah
that's Russian Ella burning plastic like
aluminum and it's very small on its
diameter but very heavy weight and
because of that it penetrates meat into
the target duplos through phones it's
[Music]
that's right
you can get them on Amazon Prime right
if you like this all right boys
successfully went through my phone
somebody's you really you're lying that
one rolling right now is a little pricey
so it's time to do the real deal now we
have sapphire black for you to keep it
over top of the target you bullseye
bullseye Kapow
this one is scared of my liquid acting
the only thing I'm worried about is you
guys the dog glasses on it behind okay
yeah yeah exactly it finish matter
here's one kicking somebody gets sick
thumbnail you need pictures down right
over top of us that's right that's got
me the thumb right there sue me yeah you
know everything okay yeah I'm going to
say okay I'm at full draw and then you
hit the button and then I'm going to
wait three and shoot this is it boys
right now I think we got having one in
one shot alright here's full drug we're
gonna have worn one shot at a weight
talk about us
alright good that ain't Underwood oh
yeah definitely
that didn't work yes sir that's the
money shot
perfected by the people in pretty good
IQs I need some alright you get further
fruit next phone iPhone with Dolby shit
out here in the rain next live here the
real world
mattified to show samsung some love as
well oh now now it's time to show
samsung some love as well we got Jon
from TLD and he said not partial only
that boy no we gotta spread the love and
why are we doing another site just not
an Jerry
let's check we need we need t-shirts
it's a porcine this flavor my racket
take that good job David yeah though my
boss I'll put you guys should just you
know you should try to do you should try
to to have that video going if that
phone works have a video going of the
arrow coming out and just blackness oh
wait
oh wow mics out good night business go
that's pretty cool hmm oh that's man
it's sizzling right now this might blow
yeah I might go that's Italy right now
[Music]
- huh - huh another HK used to we have a
problem that's why she shoot again
probably we're room sits in a blow
you're very funny
is it sizzling
[Music]
oh god yeah fatties especially these s5
men of no importance Tory oh yeah were
your heroes and being hot no when you
can't afford a man with the thing
Charlie will we were destined Wow jtro
it's probably little did a lot of led
our job Jets 90% of men should I be
awake military hard task ahead of the
attack war that's not your son we had my
graduate our puzzle you know that's that
not long ago up that's been good comment
or comparative yeah but I think on the
seven or may be able to stream at that
arrow it was ever last no monitor your
for shooting when you see it go yeah
busy already
let's do it works a modeling are all the
Jewish or or put a full row
night night baby
wait still on some as a reflection here
my house it that yeah so I want to think
of it a little better than that
s5 it as I fell under only visit to you
honey but they didn't directly proof I
would say held up a little better how to
separate a multi-step of that oh wait a
sizzling though
free all right you for draw
[Music]
I can say that's a that's one in five
have a month for I'm worried about this
one right yeah
there's our group oh this one right here
that was badass
on to that Sean denotes not very sick
there's enough like exploding porta
light is to take a second to go over
yeah right ever see it no
you
[Music]